they've been traveling the globe
searching for words and ideas at risk of
being lost forever david harrison and
reg anderson of the living tongues
institute and chris Rainier of National
Geographic were last in northern
Australia where they interviewed a man
who may be the last speaker of a
language previously thought to be
extinct nada Baylor look like my father
all right bye my father there are 7,000
known languages in the world but more
than half are expected to die out in the
coming decades that's why the trio
helped create national Geographics
enduring voices project every two weeks
around the planet a language disappears
completely disappears forever and ever
so what we're doing with the enduring
voices project is really kind of trying
to bring awareness to this whole issue
of language loss around the planet after
Australia the team continues the search
this time in the extreme north east of
India the team arrives in a large
village called home after speaking to
several villagers it seems the local
Appa Thani language is widely spoken
among the older generation but the
endurance of a language like many
aspects of culture depends on the youth
the team meets a young man named Vijay
who speaks English and a ppattani
Vijay invites them into his home remain
here with help from Indian scholar dr.
ganesh more mu the researchers record
the basics of the local language
I'm how you count one two three four one
one four one in addition to conducting
their own research the team trains
locals to use special language
technology kits each kit contains a
laptop computer digital video and still
cameras and basic digital recorders the
enduring voices team must press on but
they leave behind the technology kit so
that the community can continue to
preserve this vital part of their
heritage the recordings they make will
ensure that even if the last speaker of
a native language dies it won't be the
final word